quand on pense à de belles terres
fertiles ce qui vient en tête le plus
souvent ce sont des régions au sud la
vallée du saint laurent la péninsule du
niagara mais c'est une région plus au
nord se démarque visite du témiscamingue
un secret agricole bien gardé
[Musique]
le témiscamingue agricole est un secret
bien gardé
voisins de l'ontario plus près de
toronto que de montréal il renferme le
plus grand réservoir de terres agricoles
du québec de très grande réputation
ceux qui cultivent cette terre ils
savent tout autour du lac témiscamingue
se trouvent les meilleures terres des
fermes bien organisés sur des terres
fertiles et pourtant les moins chers du
québec
[Musique]
quand arrive le temps de moissonner à la
fin de l'été le témiscamingue agricole
est à son plus beau ça va très bien puis
la température d'abord michel robert le
saint-eugène de guigues cultive 800
hectares de terres agricoles en partie
pour le floing de son troupeau de 200
vaches laitières mais surtout pour les
grès le soya le canola vendu pour
nourrir les animaux la caméline l'orge
et le blé pour la consommation humaine
cette année il sait déjà que la farine
de son blé sera de bonne qualité
14 en une saison qui est belle qui est
des pluies régulières en vo les hippies
on a déjà une bonne idée mais c'est
vraiment au moment de la récolte quand
on arrive avec les batteurs dans le
champ c'est là qu'on va voir le test
ultime
la région du témiscamingue une région
qui au grand potentiel pour faire des
grains de grande qualité
deux raisons principales expliquent la
renommée des grains du témiscamingue
d'abord le climat les températures de
jour sont proches de celles d'ottawa et
les nuits sont froides après le coucher
du soleil le mercure peut descendre de
10 à 15 degrés
conditions idéales pour les céréales à
paille
deuxième facteur la texture du sol
nous sommes au coeur de l'immense
enclave argileuse barreaux à djibouti un
territoire unique formé de dépôt
glaciaux lacustres et recouvert de sable
et l'omsa bleus le sol et les méconnus
on marche sont les jo mais on creusera
les trous comme ça pour aller voir la
main si on est un peu des deux
mécaniques
le professeur et chercheur en sciences
du sol à l'uqat vincent poirier nous
fait voir un profil de sol c'est la
manière pour lui de lire le sol
on voit différentes couleurs on voit des
couleurs plus foncées sur le dessus un
espèce de brun puis si bien on voit une
alternance de différentes couches le
plus clair foncé donc ça ce sont ce
qu'on appelle des vagues donc on est ici
sur un profil de sol d'énergie élevée
une des grandes particularités des sols
argileux c'est que beaucoup de
particules très fines et ces particules
elles ont le potentiel de retenir les
éléments nutritifs retenir la matière
organique puis de faire en sorte que
justement ces éléments là ne vont pas
être perdu dans le profil de ça mais ils
vont rester là et naturellement il ya un
espèce de fertilité intrinsèque qui
vient avec ce type de sol
bonoua djiboua est une mer intérieure
formé à la fin de la dernière glaciation
qui recouvrait le nord-est de l'ontario
et le nord-ouest du québec en se
retirant les eaux de fonte glaciaire ont
donné naissance à ce sol des dépôt
d'argile lourde qui permettent une
datation très fine on voit par ses
cocheurs ici c'est comme un marqueur de
temps si on veut les différentes couches
bien l'enfer donc c'est une année de
dépôt et puis c'est un seul alternance
de saison était vive à
40% des sols du témiscamingue sont de
cette nature ici à ville marie on est
sur une succession de couches appelé
gearey on voit que ce sas des faits très
facilement donc c'est un très beau
profil de sol en fait
moi j'avais travaillé au début de ma
carrière pour fermer cette culture dans
glee l'agronome et préfète du
témiscamingue claire bolduc 10 le plein
épanouissement de l'agriculture de sa
région fait un potentiel qui est
associée au seul ou climat qui est
associé aussi à la qualité de
l'environnement peu de ravageurs peu de
problèmes éthiques donc on est en mesure
de montrer de déployer de développer
toutes les formes d'agriculture possible
de faire selon elle le pays est idéal
pour des produits de haut calibre que la
ferme soit micro ou plus grande
l'agriculture est branché sur une
production de qualité sur une production
innovante et sur une production
respectueuse de l'environnement
fait pas banal de pouvoir le dire pour
tout un territoire
michel robert pratique un type
d'agriculture qui rejouait cette
approche et produit des grains de
spécialités l'orge est décidé à faire de
la bière est vendue à une grande
brasserie de montréal et le blé est
réservé à une madrid qui exige un blé
exempts de pesticides
est moulé tulard travaille beaucoup en
agriculture raisonnée l'aï lecture
raisonnée cesu c'est une culture qui
était faite l'année puis un poids de
kimpese cette demie sur le blé puis
l'orge de brasserie baisser notre marché
c'est non marché niche le sait nos
marchés qu'on préconise
ce sont des cultures qui exige un plus
grand suivi de la part du producteur
mais le sol et le climat lui rendent
bien le blé du témiscamingue et fameux
de façon générale le blé du
témiscamingue est considéré comme un bly
qui corrigent des blés d'autres régions
du québec
une cinquantaine de producteurs de blé
de la région livrent leurs grains ici
dans ce centre degrés
grâce à uniformiser les lots pour être
capable de faire une expédition puis
d'avoir un client qui vont s est fait
puis pour être certain de pau se faire
refuser des voyages parce que quelque
part quand tu es à 7h de route que tu te
fais refusant voyage était un peu tu es
un peu dans le trouble
les animaux la culture des champs donne
de l'emploi à presque toute la famille
de michel robert
mais c'est aussi pour donner plus de
force à la production régionale qui l'a
investi dans ce centre de grains en 2016
mais loin des meuneries il faut y mettre
le prix à la livraison il en coûte aux
producteurs entre 35 et 40 dollars la
tonne de grecs le prix des terres est un
moins élevé bien car on finit par faire
un calcul qui fait qu' on y trouve une
rentabilité
selon le financière agricole du québec
c'est dans la grande région de
l'abitibi-témiscamingue que se trouvent
les terres de l'est moins cher en 2019
l'hectare de terres en culture au québec
valait 24000 237 $ alors que pour
l'abitibi-témiscamingue l'hectare en
culture valait 2080 de dollars
une explication le témiscamingue ne vit
pas la compétition pour l'achat de
terres présente dans le sud du québec
les terres sont généreuses et à bon prix
mais il faut avoir la manière pour
réussir à cultiver les sols de l'enclavé
russe
comme ils ont beaucoup d'argent elles
sont faciles à compacter
leurs défauts si je peux dire il faut
faire attention à la confection parce
qu'une fois que le sol est compact et
très difficile de revenir à la réalité
que les producteurs agricoles du
témiscamingue connaissent bien
ce que font qu'on y mette du drainage
c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'on y mette du
nivellement puis il faut qu'on travaille
nos rotations de cultures humaines mais
ça c'est des choses qu'on nous comme pas
du temps on est capable contre eau libre
qu'on est capable d'amateurs de l'avant
puis d'être capable d'aller chercher des
bons potentiels
pas de doute pour le chercheur le
témiscamingue à la plus grande réserve
de terres agricoles du québec
delson qui en même temps peuvent rendre
des services écologiques essentiels la
somme nous permet de filtrer l'eau le
sel nous permet de séquestrer du carbone
race 15 éléments nutritifs maintenir la
biodiversité
les modèles climatiques prévoient qu'en
la saison de croissance en
abitibi-témiscamingue devrait allonger
de 30 jours mais il faudra être prudent
selon vincent poirier et ne pas copier
le mode d'agriculture et ans et du sud
on les exploite c'est celle là mais on
les obtient et aussi on veut pas
nécessairement les appauvrir c'est au
contraire on veut les empêcher
c'est la raison pourquoi l'agronomie
préfète il voit plutôt une région
propice à la culture biologique
on a des agriculteurs des producteurs
agricoles des entrepreneurs qui sont
prêts à faire ces gestes là et qui ont
la capacité une vision et de leadership
pour suivre l'évolution la science et
pour aller de l'avant
en 2020 l'abitibi témiscamingue a
accueilli un nombre record de nouvelles
fermes ces jeunes s'engagent à mettre en
valeur plus de 4000 hectares de terres
agricoles j'avais fait à réfléchir dans
le vent 20 ans où sur la planète où on
trouvera un climat propice aux activités
agricoles avec une bonne saisonnalité
qui permet le repos des sols et contrôle
des ravageurs et de loups on a de très
bons sol avec fertilité intrinsèque à
partir du moment où il fait attention un
seul s'ils vivent michel robert est né
au témiscamingue et a toujours su qu'ils
vivaient sur une mine d'or mes parents
nous ont beaucoup
nous ont beaucoup occupé cette valeur
lot de prendre soin des sols puis de
d'avoir le privilège de cultiver ici
[Musique]